[Musique]
toute expérience de l'échec ou de la
douleur est une occasion de se dépasser
je ne sais pas ce que cette phrase vous
dit mais moi c'est une leçon que j'ai
apprise de ma grand mère maternelle
quand j'étais petite ma grand mère me
disait souvent
l'important dans la vie c'est de
persévérer
quoi qu'il advienne il ne faut jamais
renoncer à nos patients elle même en
savait quelque chose car il avait
traversé deux guerres mondiales la
grippe espagnole qui avait emporté son
père et la grande dépression on l'a
retirée très tôt de l'école alors
qu'elle était première de classe et
qu'elle voulait étudier
c'était une autre époque au lieu de
devenir architecte
comme elle l'aurait souhaité ma grand
mère est devenue couturière chez elle
elle confectionnait des vêtements robes
vestes manteaux cardigan pu il me
répétait qu'elle voulait vivre jusqu'à
100 ans
elle me disait souvent un bel ouvrage
comprend toujours des finitions
élégantes
il faut regarder à l'envers d'un
vêtement pour juger de sa qualité
elle m'a aussi appris à lire un plan de
couture plus tard j'ai étudié la
littérature et un jour je me suis
installé à montréal
je me suis beaucoup promené dans la
ville au fil de mes recherches et de mes
déambulations j'ai commencé à lire la
ville à l'envers qu'est ce que cela veut
dire
cela consiste à se tenir à l'affût des
traces des échos des signes qui se
trouvent sur des enseignes des façades
des immeubles dans les une arrière cour
dans un hall d'entrée tous ces indices
nous informent sur la vie grouillante
de dawn immeuble d'une rue d'un quartier
sur les habitants qui ont jadis vécu
dans ces immeubles et dans ces quartiers
et sur l'histoire de la ville vous
connaissez peut-être la tradition des
flâneurs de charles baudelaire à valter
benjamin ces promeneurs solitaires qui
ont écrit leur propre parcours ou qui
sont devenu architecte de leur propre
trajectoire
c'est comme cela que j'ai commencé à
découvrir le morial yddish une ville
fabuleuse inédite
autrefois on l'appelait décline irish
times fond d'amérique la petite
jérusalem d'amérique et le mont royal la
montagne au centre de la ville évoqué
les collines de jérusalem
je vais vous raconter vous vous demandez
peut-être
qu'est ce que c'est exactement le
yiddish
c'est la langue vernaculaire des juifs
ashkénazes originaires de l'europe
centrale c'est une langue germanique qui
se dit de gauche à droite et qui utilise
l'alphabet hébraïque
cette langue est rente intimement liés
aux diverses migration juive a longtemps
été dépréciés on l'a qualifié de jargon
et pourtant elle se trouve à l'origine
d'un riche paul folklore d'une abondante
littérature et de vifs élan
révolutionnaire au début du 20e siècle
montréal fut la deuxième ville
d'amérique après new york à accueillir
des immigrants juifs
à cette période la culture yiddish était
en pleine effervescence dans les grands
centres européens dont varsovie berlin
et paris
plusieurs artistes de renom était
invitée régulièrement à montréal
ce fut le cas notamment du grand
écrivain et voyageur scholem h
en 1930
le yiddish et est la troisième langue
parlée couramment dans les grandes
artères de la ville depuis le port
jusqu'au plateau mont royal
même si les anglophones et les
francophones ne la comprenait pas ces
intonations leur était familière car il
était entouré par sa présence il faut
dire qu'à cette période les commerçants
juifs avaient l'habitude d'afficher sur
des enseignes le nom de leur commerce
on y dîne en europe ces gens avaient
vécu dans des contextes de xénophobie et
de persécution plusieurs d'entre eux
avaient cumulé des expériences limites
des traumas personnel et collectif
l'antisémitisme cela vous dit quelque
chose
on en parle beaucoup dans les médias
depuis quelques temps bien que l'on
n'associe ce phénomène souvent au passé
il demeure très présent
encore aujourd'hui malgré tout les juifs
d'europe qui ont émigré vers l'ouest
étaient fascinés et plein d'espoir pour
eux
l'amérique c'était la gourde de médine
continent 9 à habiter les artisans du
morial yddish étaient des architectes
prodigieux dès leur arrivée vers l'année
1910 ils se sont construit une ville
entière
ils ont fondé leur propre institution
les écoliers dish la bibliothèque
publique juive la presse le théâtre
le congrès juif canadien l'hôpital
général juif de montréal pour ne nommer
que celles là
comme l'a écrit l'intellectuel des
vitraux ce qu'ils
c'était une expérience utopique car
cette communauté n'avait pas de racines
sur le territoire nord américain
plusieurs d'entre eux étaient écrivains
artistes activistes en même temps il
travaillait dans les usines de
confection
certains exerçait le métier de tailleur
une profession répandue parmi les juifs
d'europe
il habitait le quartier populaire du
plateau mont royal où étaient déjà
installés les québécois francophones
avec ceux ci
il fréquentait des espaces communs
le monument national le parc jeanne
mance le marché saint jean baptiste
michel tremblay dans son roman la grosse
femme d'à côté est enceinte a bien
décrit les activités des canadiens
français qui vont faire leurs courses
chez les marchands juifs du marché saint
jean baptiste
les syndicats et les usines de
confection était d'autres espaces où les
individus des deux communautés se
rencontrer fréquemment mais pourtant ils
ne se sont jamais vraiment véritablement
rencontré car il y avait une barrière
infranchissable la langue première
barrière et une deuxième fort importante
la religion après la seconde guerre
mondiale d'autres juifs d'europe sont
arrivés en masse
c'était pour la plupart des survivants
de la shoah l'holocauste
la grande catastrophe au cours de
laquelle six millions d'individus ont
péri pour la simple raison qu'ils
étaient nés juifs en l'espace de
quelques années ils ont participé au
renouveau de la vie littéraire
artistique et politique de montréal et
moi j'étais fasciné par leur énergie par
la vitalité de ces individus qui ne
s'était pas laisser arrêter par les
discours officiels
alors qu'il n'était pas très bien perçu
puisque n'étant ni catholique ni
francophone il n'était pas reçu tout à
fait comme de bons étrangers
après avoir vécu des expériences limites
aux confins de la mort il avait encore
l'énergie de poursuivre
le montréal yddish c'est donc un univers
cosmopolite qui se distingue par sa
force et par sa façon singulière
d'incarner la modernité littéraire et
artistique
un excellent exemple de cette situation
dans la diaspora est celui de marc
chagall
il y a quelques années mes travaux sur
la rue sur la littérature yiddish m'ont
amené à faire des recherches ou ivo
l'institut scientifique juifs à new york
en tant que boursière fait un moment
très important de mon parcours j'ai
alors découvert l'autobiographie de
jeunesse de marc chagall en yiddish qui
savait que chagall avait lui dit pour
langue maternelle
on croyait qu'ils l'utérus et qu'il
avait d'abord écrit dans cette langue
ce qui est faux
la découverte du tapuscrit de chagall
m'a incité à entreprendre la traduction
de ce texte dont je voulais rétablir
l'authenticité
je voulais rendre la voix de chagall en
français l'ouvragé très connues du
peintre intitulé ma vie avait à l'époque
était largement reconstruit avec l'aide
de l'éditeur
les expressions colorées de chagall son
ton mordant et son univers onirique
avaient pour la plupart disparus le
résultat est bien celle ouvrage de marc
chagall mon univers autobiographie
traduit par moi même et pierre anctil
il a été lancé en janvier 2010 est en
même temps que l'ouverture de
l'exposition marc chagall couleurs et
musiques au musée des beaux-arts de
montréal
mais pourquoi me suis intéressé à un
monde si différent de celui dans lequel
j'ai grandi je dois dire que j'ai été à
bonne école
dès mon enfance l'ouverture sur le monde
m'a été enseignée par certainement
brrr de ma famille et par mon éducation
la rencontre de la culture yiddish a
transformé ma vision de l'histoire
québécoise et elle a changé mon parcours
de chercheuse et d'écrivaine elle m'a
invité à observer un changement de
paradigme
face à ce que j'avais déjà appris je
vous explique
au québec on dit habituellement que la
modernité a émergé après la seconde
guerre mondiale en littérature avec
gabrielle roy et son roman urbain
bonheur d'occasion publié en 1945 en
arts visuels avec paul émile borduas et
les signataires du manifeste refus
global datant de 1948
le constat qui s'impose si l'on ne s'en
tient pas seulement à la culture
francophone c'est que le monde yddish a
apporté la modernité au québec dès les
années 1920 en littérature au théâtre et
en politique
le montréal yddish c'est donc une ville
palimpseste qui recèle différentes
strates d'histoire c'est une forte
présence dont je m'efforce de recueillir
les traces et les échos depuis plusieurs
années dans mes ouvrages notamment à la
découverte du morial yiddish et voyez 10
ch de montréal et la communauté juive il
faut le rappeler représente le premier
exemple de diversité socioculturelle au
québec
au 20ème siècle ce fut le premier groupe
le plus important sur le plan de
l'immigration pendant 50 ans ensuite
sont arrivés les chinois les grecs les
italiens les portugais et plusieurs
autres on lui doit une contribution
exceptionnelle à la vie littéraire
artistique et politique de montréal
cette communauté à participer au
développement de la ville actuelle celle
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui à
travers la promotion de ces valeurs de
tolérance et de respect des droits
humains
aujourd'hui encore elle participe au
développement d'une société démocratique
pour le futur je vous ai parlé de ma
grand mère dans sa maison il y avait
toujours des travaux de couture en cours
textile patron fils ruban ciseaux
s'amoncelaient dans une grande pièce
autour des machines à coudre
ça me rappelle une idée qui traverse la
pensée juive dans une maison juive il y
a toujours quelque chose d'un complet ou
d'inachevé cette idée dérive d'un
principe de la torah c'est à dire que le
monde est imparfait car il est toujours
en mouvement
tout est en constante évolution et c'est
grâce à cet aspect inachevé que la
lumière entre que la vie circulent et
continue vous le savez sans doute déjà
grâce à la parole la plus connue de
leonard cohen
verizon crack in every thing dao de
light jet henin avant de devenir
l'auteur compositeur interprète de
renommée internationale que l'on connaît
leonard cohen était poète après la mort
de son père survenue lorsqu'il était
jeune garçon sa vocation de poète s'est
imposé ainsi il n'est pas devenu le
patron de la compagnie friedman
l'entreprise de confection familiale qu
avait fondé son grand père il faut
rappeler qu'il est issu d'un milieu
nancy où les berceuses en yiddish et
l'élégance vestimentaire jouer un rôle
important
c'est pour cela qu'on a dit de lui qu'il
était né en costume 1
et pourtant la brisure s'inscrit au
coeur de son parcours il y a une idée
importante qui traversent son oeuvre
pour créer il faut d'abord faire
l'expérience de l'échec ou si vous le
voulez il faut utiliser les chèques pour
transcender la douleur qui nous habite
et faire oeuvre de création
c'est ce qui a forgé son caractère de
ténébreux romantique
c'est ce qui lui a permis de se
réinventer à plusieurs reprises après
des moments difficiles que l'échec
invite au dépassement de soi et à la
création fait une idée qui fait écho
vous l'avez deviné aux propos de ma
grand mère et ma grand mère si elle n'a
pu devenir architecte
et bien elle a cependant réalisé son
deuxième rêve elle a vécu jusqu'à 100
ans tout est possible il est possible de
se réinventer malgré la chute la maladie
la guerre l'immigration le désespoir que
l'on soit né dans une petite ville
d'amérique ou dans un château une
bourgade de pologne
il est possible de se recréer un univers
de couture ou de poésie
il est possible d'inventer une nouvelle
ville et de devenir centenaire
ensemble il est possible de fabriquer
une oeuvre collective en lisant à
l'envers et en cousant à l'endroit il
est possible de construire une grande
braderie avec nos identités plurielles
nos langues diverses et nos discours
métissé pour moi traduire la langue et
la culture yiddish
c'est un acte comparable au métier de
tailleur en confection c'est à la fois
un acte de résistance et de combat
un geste d'hospitalité et de générosité
traduire du yiddish c'est une forme
hommage la prochaine fois que vous vous
promènerez dans une métropole d'amérique
regardez bien autour de vous à travers
les lézardes des anciens murs les trous
et de certains immeubles vous apercevrez
quelques lueurs ainsi vous pourriez
découvrir quelques fragments de vie qui
composent la stratigraphie urbaine et
qui font rayonner la ville aujourd'hui
dans toute sa diversité
[Applaudissements]